maybe this  no b2 there's bishop c1  the two black pieces can't defend each  other  wow what a game as soon as magnus got  down to five minutes he just  enacted kind of  genius mode  yeah  he found this great and  oh there we go another resignation hot  off the heels of the other game karjakin  resigns and magnus takes the lead in the  tournament for the first time  well he had a very difficult day and he  was um  yeah he was on the brink very crazy game  yeah magnus there we see he's not happy  that's probably because of the way he  played the opening  and the middle early middle game  defended when he needed to yeah today it  was uh  i mean sergey played well we have to we  have to say he played well so it was  quite unfortunate for him that  after d4 happened that he couldn't even  make it hold the game